[Aplausos]
en lugar de decirme carla esto debes
hacer esto no debes de hacer esto está
bien o esto está mal mi papá prefiere
contarme historias sus historias son lo
que ha formado las decisiones que tomo
en la vida mucho más de lo que él se
puede imaginar les doy un ejemplo cuando
tenía 10 años mi papá vivió una de las
situaciones más escalofriantes que
alguien se puede imaginar regresando de
una cena familiar en cuernavaca se
encuentra con una de las mangas flotando
boca abajo en la alberca
y papá se echa inmediatamente al agua
saca la jovencita de la alberca intenta
desesperadamente todo lo posible por
revivir la sin ningún éxito yo no me
enteré hasta años después de lo que pasó
pero mi papá me cuenta que esa noche
acostado en la cama sin poder dormir lo
único que puede ver es la imagen de la
pobre niña flotando en la alberca así
que decide pararse en la cama rennes a
la alberca sentarse en una silla mirando
fijamente la alberca viendo el trauma
frente a frente incómodo
las imágenes resurgiendo el cuerpo de lo
mojado su familia la muerte la culpa los
hubieras corriendo por su mente porque
nos fuimos a cenar porque se metió a
nadar solas y no sabía cómo nadar como
porque hubiera
sigue enfrentando sentado en esa silla
sin querer separar hasta poder vencer
esos pensamientos
pasan siete horas apenas empieza a salir
el sol y mi papá intenta recordar otros
momentos momentos felices que también
habíamos vivido en esa alberca
vacaciones juegos risas y poco a poco
esa imagen o ese trauma empezaron a
perder poder sobre mi papá
en los momentos donde yo más quiero
salir corriendo huir evadir un acuerdo
de esta historia sus historias
me invitan a atreverme a lo cómodo a lo
que más me da miedo
y hoy ese es el caso
cuando me invitaron a dar una
conferencia excepto mi primera reacción
fue ni de loca
no no inviten me a actuar cualquier
personaje a interpretar a una borracha a
cantarles desentonada un pedante una
perturbada perversa criminal a una
estudiante de leyes asesina lo que
quieran y felices los hago mismo pidan
me interpretará la actriz y posar en
frente de las cámaras en hollywood
frente de todas las estrellas de
hollywood con tacones incómodos
demasiado maquillaje sonreír y contestar
esas preguntas indiscretas que les
encanta hacer
pidan hacer eso y felices los hago pero
pedirme que sea yo misma
y quitarme las máscaras de los
personajes con las que me escondo
venir a este escenario y exponerme
honesta y sinceramente con ustedes el
resultado son retortijones en el
estómago insomnio y muchas ganas de
decir no perdón es que por la agenda no
web
así que espero que mi papá esté
orgulloso de que estoy aquí con ustedes
sus historias son mi herencia y son lo
que me mueven en la dirección menos
cómoda vivimos en una sociedad donde
tratamos de evadir esos momentos
incómodos esos momentos difíciles a toda
costa una sociedad que nos vende ideas
ideas que en mi opinión son mentiras muy
bien maquilladas desde las sencillas
como
sin ejercicio ni dieta pierde 15 kilos
en 2 días
aprende todo un idioma en tan solo dos
semanas o los útiles filtros que les
ponemos a las fotos que subimos a las
redes sociales que son versiones
perfectas e irreales de quiénes somos y
nos ahogan cuando tratamos de mantener
esa imagen o ese estado
lo que me dicen de las vidas de rafa
márquez rodolfo neri iñárritu o frida
kahlo que nos pintan como seres
superdotados que únicamente llegaron al
éxito por su talento
y no por horas y horas de experiencia
trabajo y fracaso a diario
lo peor es que nos creemos esas mentiras
no saben las veces que la gente llega a
mí y me dice carla como lo hago para
lograr mis sueños en la vida es que
quiero ser actriz no sabes mi mamá y mi
tía me dicen que soy buenísima
y cuando les pregunto bueno y qué clases
o qué cursos estás tomando
bueno pues es que todavía no pero pero
bueno es que mi mamá y mi tía me dicen
que ya estoy lista para empezar a actuar
mentira en un vídeo de cuando tenía 12
años
actuando para un proyecto de la escuela
para que se den cuenta que mis ganas de
ser actriz no era suficiente para
hacerlo
[Aplausos]
ven como era importante que fuera a
estudiar horas y horas
si va tomando clases de actuación
y autor bueno uno de mis autores
favoritos malcom gladwell prueba esta
teoría en su libro outliers toma casos
de éxitos y genios que normalmente
pensamos que así nacieron superdotados y
calcula que en realidad tuvieron más de
10.000 horas de experiencia y estudio en
su campo antes de ser titulados genios o
expertos
yo practique gimnasia olímpica durante 8
años entrenaba 5 horas diarias de lunes
a sábado con llagas en las manos dejando
sangre en las barras me tenía que seguir
esforzando sabiendo que lo tenía que
hacer para seguir siendo parte del
equipo
levantando me a las 5 de la mañana para
ir a entrenar antes de la escuela
sacrificando viajes fiestas no viejitos
esos 8 años me enseñaron que la medalla
de oro no se gana accidentalmente el
músculo se tiene que desgarrar
para crecer el músculo se tiene que
desgarrar
para poder crecer aunque entiendo la
ciencia detrás de esto entonces porque
aún así maldigo los momentos en los que
la adversidad me toca la puerta imaginen
esto estoy en el primer día
en la escuela de actuación en londres
audición and cinco mil chavos y solo
aceptan a quince mujeres y a quince
hombres así que como pueden imaginarse
me siento un poquito demasiado especial
es el primer día llega a uno de los
profesores más respetados y nos dice en
cinco años sólo tres de los treinta que
están aquí van a tener trabajo en esta
carrera
como 10% pero
digo si todos somos talentosos no no
creo que sea tan difícil y conforme
fueron pasando los meses seis se
salieron el primer año unos cambiaron
cambiaron de profesión de carrera unos
los perdimos por crisis emocionales y
mentales y mismo un amigo mío robben uno
de los actores más talentosos de esa
escuela
se suicidó
es difícil cualquier carrera que ustedes
quieran hacer es iba a ser difícil
entonces cuál es tu gasolina
que hará que aguantes bar en los
momentos más oscuros más difíciles con
los que te vas a encontrar que es como
diría una abogada en la serie de
hardware with meter tu motivo no juzgo
si tu motivo es ser millonario si tu
motivo es ser famoso lograr que tu ex se
arrepienta de haberte cortado
está bien lo único que digo es que ese
motivo debe estar tan arraigado a tu ser
tan impregnado en tu piel que no importa
la tormenta el rechazo la crítica que
recibas ese motivo hará que te levantes
y que le sigas dando
carla perdón estamos buscando a alguien
más famoso para este papel
levántate carla anales citar la estamos
buscando alguien menos famoso por este
papel más latina menos latina más flaca
menos flaca analizarla síguele siegel
la cantidad de nuevos rechazo y críticas
que recibe a diario varían de
comentarios de productores como esos
y comentarios en twitter como
no pues no me gusta tu actuación
estás guapa pero estás bien vista
patas de pollo o comentarios de
familiares y amigos
carla porque te vas a ir a hollywood
estás loca ubícate nunca la vas a hacer
i
dónde iba
así un día
recibo aviso de un casting para una
película llamada el jesuita escrita por
el mismo cuate que escribió 'taxi
driver' de rating pero está buscando una
actriz de mi edad así que le llama la
señorita del casting carla perdón lo que
pasa es que los productores están
buscando alguien que pueda los
productores no creen que puedan puedas
interpretar este papel bueno conocí a
uno de los productores así que le llamo
karl a mí a lo que pasa es que estamos
buscando alguien que pueda interpretar
una texana tosca y racista perfecto yo
yo puedo darte eso claro carry también
lo que pasa es que el director cree que
eres muy muy bonita muy delicada
estamos buscando alguien que parezca una
drogadicta
me vuelve bueno estoy enojada y
frustrada porque sólo quería tener la
oportunidad de hacer la audición pero ni
siquiera eso me quieren dar así que
consigo el guión me aprendo una escena
le pido a mis amigos machistas y
peinadores que me ayuden a verme menos
delicada
rento una cámara unas luces y al día
siguiente le mando esto al productor
licenciados
sainz
bao
brassens
pasaron dos semanas y no recibe
contestación al email
de repente recibe una llamada y es el
productor con el director
carla te ofrecemos el papel
nos filmamos la película pero que cree
en la película no ha salido y ni
siquiera sé si vaya a salir
ojalá y sí pero a veces se siente que el
esfuerzo no valió para nada pero esa
experiencia no me la quita nadie y
además le agregué a mis 10.000 horas
el éxito es la habilidad de ir de
fracaso en fracaso con entusiasmo como
bien lo dijo churchill y yo creo que un
buen motivo te puede ayudar a hacer eso
sin embargo me motivo no siempre ha sido
el mismo cambio hace ocho años
drásticamente estaba al final de mi
primer año de los tres años de la
carrera de actuación en londres
un día sin razón alguna pierdo el habla
durante tres meses no puedo hablar
durante tres meses no puedo decir ni un
miserable enunciado ni los doctores ni
los electroencefalogramas han podido
explicarme qué fue lo que realmente pasó
lo que sí les puedo decir es que llegó
un momento de tanta frustración y tanta
desesperación que llegué a quererme
quitar la vida
en ese momento busco dentro de mí la
fuerza que yo creía tener busco la ayuda
de mi familia de mis amigos mi fe en
dios y no encuentro
no hay cura no es salida me motivo mi
gasolina rápidos y empieza a desvanecer
y se acaba
y el infierno en el que me encuentro sin
embargo
se vuelve un poquito menos pesado cuando
empiezo a ver mi dolor
el mismo tipo de dolor reflejado en las
obras de arte de otras personas
las obras de teatro
en las películas
en las pinturas
poco a poco empiezo a ver mi dolor y lo
empiezo a leer en los poemas
las palabras de los poetas y de los
personajes empiezan a llenar mis
silencios empiezan a ser la única forma
que la que yo sentía que mis emociones
estaban siendo expresadas
leo mi dolor en los poemas deseo día
plas entumecida me inclino a ti
entumecida como un fósil dime que estoy
aquí
me conecto con el cuestionamiento
constante de la vida en los libros de
jager la veo las pinturas de frida kahlo
y por primera vez puedo palpar ese
sufrimiento y esa soledad de sus
autorretratos el arte se convierte en
algo vivo durante esos tres meses de
silencio depresión y angustia me enamoré
inexplicable completa y totalmente del
arte
el sufrimiento me llevo como un clavo al
corazón de dios
y me entristece saber que hay gente que
no cree que el arte es digno de nuestra
atención y de nuestro financiamiento
porque para mí no es sólo una pasión
es lo que me salvó la vida lo que me
mantuvo vida
otra prueba llegó hace tres años cuando
me gané la lotería me enamoré de un
hombre llamémosle pedro por conservar su
anonimato
me quería casar con pedro o sea que
estaba muy enamorada fui descubriendo
que la familia de pedro aquí en méxico
es muy poderosa tenían muchísimo dinero
mucho más de lo que yo imaginaba que
existía mucho más de lo que podría
gastarme en toda una vida un día me
sientan me dicen carla
te adoramos queremos que seas parte de
nuestra familia solo tenemos una
condición deja la actuación
te apoyamos en lo que quieras en
cualquier otra profesión que elijas pero
deja la actuación porque si sigues
actuando no vas a poder ser una esposa
fiel no vas a poder ser una buena madre
y queremos lo mejor para ti
me ardían los ojos
el llanto
y le digo adiós a la media vuelta y
salgo sin saber que iba a ser de mi vida
pero sabiendo eso si
el llamado que dios tiene mi vida mis
sueños y mi pasión no tienen precio y
esa historia le encanta a mi marido
que está aquí
por qué les cuento estas historias
porque la gente normalmente cree que el
éxito y la fama son algo maravilloso y
fácil de navegar
estas pruebas a mí para mí generan
frutos como el perdón
la perseverancia la disciplina el
carácter y la esperanza son lo que
afilan mi oficio y lo que con mucha
mucha paciencia van afinando mi ser
y me liberan del orgullo he aprendido
que el aplauso
dura sólo un momento y esa fama que
buscamos es tan obsesivamente es una
mera burbuja que tan fácilmente se
poncha
no tengo la fórmula secreta de cómo
lograr tus sueños y metas en la vida
yo sigo aprendiendo conforme avanzó con
la ayuda de las historias de mi papá me
sigo aprendiendo a enfrentar mis miedos
le sigo agregando a mis diez mil horas
para lograr excelencia en mi oficio y me
sigo atreviendo a usar los sufrimientos
para que me continúen llevando como un
clavo al corazón de dios
algunas ideas y descubrimientos
personales que tenemos en la vida de
alguna forma no pueden ser compartidas
no pueden ser explicadas solo pueden ser
reveladas sólo pueden ser vividas sin
embargo espero que las palabras de mi
compadre william shakespeare puedan
resonar con ustedes a lo largo de su
camino
dulces son los frutos de la adversidad
que como un saco feo y venenoso lleva en
la cabeza una presión bajo ya la
adversidad
muchas veces
se ve como ese saco
feo y venenoso
pero que haga que llegue
cada que surge el desafío ahora que lo
pienso en el camino si descargo
me encuentro con una preciosa joya
gracias
[Aplausos]